you starting the show yeah okay go ahead
kick it off take it off to you well I've
been waiting for you to do it cuz it's
like sometimes you tell me like that you
want to do it just depends on how I feel
at the time okay so I'm just like
sitting there looking at him going are
you gonna daily show it's Thursday you
got it which you probably know if you're
watching this already
I can't wait for Friday why a drink oh
dude I'm trying to put on a show I'm
trying to put on yeah we although I have
I do have some whiskey though so when
you do that if I need to we got and we
got enough to have a drink tonight okay
but just one
okay well that's fine I don't want to do
one it's never stay for chrissake we're
not those wrong well really I'm like but
Friday we'd have to go and make a booze
run yeah we all get to Mactan and my
eyepatch ready actually that's cool
around here now it's it's it's laxed up
a lot well yeah there's really not like
I said we haven't really had too much
trouble it's like it's a little bit of a
pain like it's a little bit of weirdness
like when you go to the you know a
grocery store and stuff and you just
have to like walk up the aisles like are
all one-way and stuff but other than
that it's not really everyone's pretty
chill around here but yeah so did you
have anything in particular that you
needed to discuss today no not so much
today just you know I was just watching
videos about you know like the
entertainment I like there's a show out
there on YouTube called Midnight's edge
and this dude does deep analysis I sent
you a link to it you didn't get a chance
to see it had to do with Disney but just
of what Disney this guy here he's good
he's almost kind of like like he's as
good as the as the guy who does all
those reviews what's his name Oliver
Harper yeah he's like that good but he's
mostly like about the business behind
the scenes right of what they're
thinking you know in terms of marketing
there and he was just talking about what
Disney was thinking with the new Star
Wars property and and why they did
certain things
and why the last Jedi was a certain way
why the force awakens was a certain way
and what you know all the new movies he
explained every one of them and had a
lot of stuff to back it up like things
that were mentioned from you know like
interviews from people that work at
Disney you know so an ex Disney
employees what was going it it's it's a
pretty revealing video you just put it
out today
Midnight's edge about Kathleen Kennedy's
and Disney's plan for the original Star
Wars and it was just like a a studying
what not to do but I understand the
thinking that they thought you know and
what they were thinking at the time it
just didn't work you know over
complicating things Dan the the the
moral of the story is don't piss off the
old fans of any franchise it comes back
to bite you in the ass that was the
moral of the story but he proved that
that's what they were trying to do I
found to be very interesting yeah yeah I
haven't like you know watch because you
know I didn't find the new Star Wars
movies and I don't really like care that
much to well I learned I try to learn
about things you know the business
aspects behind it to learn what to do
and what not to do you know we're always
talking about movies and you know series
and everything and it was just kinda
goes to show you that Disney was not
ready to manage these big [ __ ] movie
properties they just didn't have the
experience who they were hiring and what
they were thinking and just it would
have been a lot better if it was like in
in in the hands of like a real Hollywood
studio that had experience on that kind
of stuff right they just they just
mismanaged it anyway [ __ ] happens you
know you know that was [ __ ] expensive
property that they [ __ ] crash but you
know like I said [ __ ] happens and then
and that kind of happens all the time
with a lot of companies that it doesn't
even have to do with entertainment or
anything like that like sometimes it'll
be like some great idea some food
company they're like hey we're gonna buy
this [ __ ] you know Sara Lee we're
gonna buy this like food company over
here like thinking that
it's gonna go this way and it doesn't
get right anybody so far so it's like a
big money loss so far the best
management I've ever seen of any
properties that was broccoli the one
that owns bond yeah over all those
decades they were able to hold that
brand together yeah I mean yeah there
were a couple bad James Bond movies but
they were all passable pretty much yeah
I mean I got kind of cheesy in the
eighties but everything was cheesy and
yeah they were just serving the market
of the time yeah and another example
would have been Marvel the Marvel
Universe that was that was incredible
how they managed those properties yeah
they made all the money ever right the
problem was it did a made a lot of money
and made a lot of people happy it would
that's not artistic cinema though that's
the McDonald's okay they're fun they
made money and it's like I know a lot of
people are into him and stuff I you know
I saw a bunch of them and they were fine
it's not ones that I would like seek out
necessarily because in general I'm not a
real big fan of like big like tentpole
type movies like some of them were good
and I'll watch them and they're fun and
stuff like that but it's not really my
favorite yeah genre or my favorite you
know I prefer like horror movies and you
like indie horror movies you know what I
mean yeah there's a there's some good
there's some good superhero movies
though oh yeah I'm not yeah nothing that
I'm just you know Superman Juan is a
[ __ ] classic and so was Superman -
yeah the old ones Joker that was a
[ __ ] City that was a super I kind of
feel like it's cool now because Marvel
did something that they had been trying
to do for a long time like during the
80s and stuff which was trying to make
like a good like a serious superhero
movie because it seems like for a long
time
studios thought they kind of saw
superhero movies as like just stupid
dumb like for kids you know I mean more
and they didn't really take them
seriously as far as storytelling or
character development or anything like
that so I think that was one way that
Marvel was so successful was they made
these I mean they're fun movies but they
took them serious yeah they took the
stories although you don't actually that
you actually don't have to in a certain
way because another one that I thought
was just absolutely fantastic was
[ __ ] Shazam yeah
that [ __ ] was funny as [ __ ] yeah I'm not
true to the [ __ ] yeah I'm not saying
that the movie has to be serious
right I'm saying that they need to have
a serious seriously right and not just
do it as some like lame-ass cash grab
that they don't give a [ __ ] about
evidently the rock would have had a lot
to do with Shazam I think he produced it
or think it was done with yeah he
produces a lot of he said he said as
soon as you know three days into the
manoa opening he came out on instagram
and thanked everybody and said that part
two is on the way I'd [ __ ] would love
to see it yeah I would like to see a
part I really was just I had fun it
reminded me of being a kid
yeah Shazam you know I mean that's what
I mean where's my fun guileless kind of
yeah what it was like to see Hebrew I
felt like I was [ __ ] 12 again
watching for have goofy it wasn't good
yeah it was goofy it was oopy but the
tone was perfect but fun yeah for Shazam
that was that's it whatever happened
with speaking of the rock whatever
happened with fighting with my family
did that do very well because I don't
know I really liked that I'm going a lot
I want that on blu-ray and I feel like
it was kind of a little bit underrated
or under seen excellent movie yeah if
you guys haven't seen fight with my
family that's a good [ __ ] my
feel-good movie it's up it's just it's
just a good movie yeah and the rocks in
it and we repeat it when it came because
we saw in the theater when it came an
excellent movie it's probably somebody's
gotta be streaming it I think I saw it
on streaming like I would like to own
that movie on blu-ray yeah because I
would definitely watch that again oh
yeah plus like you know the rock isn't
in Florence pew is in it she's good and
it's it's a movie about [ __ ] this
success and I mean it's a feel-good
movie you walk out of it go man that was
fun yeah even if you don't give a [ __ ]
about wrestling which I generally don't
but it's like it's just still like a
really good like underdog type story and
like all the personalities of the people
are like really cute interesting yeah
cute girls wrestling girls wrestling
yeah [ __ ] the rock be in the rock
[ __ ] like Dwayne Johnson I just just
he seems like a lovely man yes he really
does
he's man crushable oh man credible yeah
I respect him
he's just use be a nice guy yeah
something else I want to make something
movies he does yeah Jumanji I like to
love Jumanji it was good and he really
doesn't like he wants to like he'll put
his name and his money behind properties
that he likes and that he believes in so
I think yeah pretty cool but he was was
he Hobbs and shawty was in Hobbs and
shout to that was a good one yeah yeah
yeah yeah he was in some a bunch of
those fast in the Furious movies
although I think I've only seen I said
we saw Hobbs and Shah in the theater and
I think I maybe saw the first one yeah
that's about it that was a big goofy
action movie it was I liked it though I
liked it too because it just got more
and more outrageous yeah I guess it went
on and I was just like a right over here
for it they're not true rock is like
holding down a [ __ ] helicopter you
are like by a chain and [ __ ] like that
whether or not they're not trying to
deceive you about is what it is like you
don't have to be like well actually
we're not able to do that oh my god just
watch the [ __ ] it was the same economy
that Arnold would have been in yes it's
like now True Lies something yeah was
always like kind of ridiculous like yeah
top stunts that probably in real life
wouldn't go the way that it go you can't
be driving a truck and then holding on a
dam you know when we were doing sling
loads and stuff you could grab the skid
of a [ __ ] helicopter and move it a
little bit yeah but that's because but
that's just because the pilots holding
the damn helicopter neutral right he's
just trying to hover so you can offset
it just a little bit you know
we noticed that so it's not that big of
a duration I know but if ya there sup I
mean I think can [ __ ] lift a fire
it's like oh yeah you know fly it off
into the [ __ ] sunset but a [ __ ]
you know what do you call a damn thing I
don't know [ __ ] ch-47 is you H wants
you know [ __ ] what's the name of that
[ __ ]
back off okay think about Huey's and
Blackhawks and Chinooks and [ __ ] you
know Black Hawk can't lift a [ __ ]
Humvee yeah if it wants to go up it's
going up there you ain't stopping it
even if you're the rock what does right
yeah I got I can't remember the exact
thing they were just on that road road
remember that flying off a cliff I can't
remember exactly what happened I just
remember seeing him doing it he was
trying he was caught in between
something wasn't it like around he was
trying to hold it either that or he was
trying to keep the truck from falling
off the cliff something like I can't
remember exactly what the logistics of
it I was just imagining his arms popping
out of his sockets at times I was that's
what really what happened pulled his
[ __ ] arms off like yeah just [ __ ]
pop your arms right out of your off your
[ __ ] body these one of them would go
yeah just like you were a [ __ ] Ken
doll yeah cuz remember how we were
talking about like some of our favorite
new wave and post-punk bands yesterday
and I said I was sure I was forgetting a
bunch oh I forgot a bunch I went through
like a list and stuff and then I had a
couple people like in the comments
because I think I mentioned I mentioned
the teardrop explodes and somebody said
oh you like the teardrop explodes but
not echo and the Bunnymen and I was like
oh my god I can't believe I could forgot
Ikon the bunny but because they're not
only when I have my bad to beshte fast
mode to COO you forgot to mention it we
forgot to go yeah you know well that you
know like I said I made like a list of
other ones that I forgot that I should
have that I should have mentioned but
echo and the Bunnymen not only do I have
like a whole bunch of their songs on my
phone that I listen to while I'm walking
but also as I said in the YouTube
comments they were actually the first
live show that I went to when I was 15
years old or I saw them at Bob Carr at
at Orion which is not there anymore
because I think they tore it down to
make the [ __ ] that big huge it used
to be called the Orlando arena and now
it's called the what the [ __ ] is that
big arena called I don't even remember
now it's like some business my first my
first live show concert that I saw must
guess I must have been about 14 13 or 14
and
is in Mississippi and I went down to the
coast
Markel or not Michael Michael Knight ma
with my cousin he was old enough to be
my uncle he just you know yeah probably
about 15 years older than me in time I
went to go see Judas Priest yeah saw the
turbo tour that's pretty cool though yes
like cuz I do notice that likes dad to
go down there for a [ __ ] business
thing anyway and and and Judas Priest
was playing like so he's like I'll drop
you off there you can watch it and [ __ ]
he didn't go with me yeah just I went
there by myself I was shocked when
[ __ ] rob halford came out there on
stage and [ __ ] he had a [ __ ] uh
dude on the back of his [ __ ] bicycle
yeah yeah [ __ ] dressed up [ __ ]
you're like he's gay yeah what the [ __ ]
is going on no no no of course well I
guess you're a 13 years I'm 34 didn't
matter everybody else but it was you
know simple uxie so [ __ ] you know the
crowd [ __ ] went wild anyway and
[ __ ] dude jumped off he was and he
look like something looks like something
out of Mad Max remember with man bags
with yeah yeah it's like that dude
jumped off the back when he [ __ ] let
when he walked off the stage he was
wearing [ __ ] shafts and he had a
[ __ ] bikini shorts on underneath the
chance the guy yeah and on the back of
him shorts as a [ __ ] target quite
honest look either like a Darnell it was
obvious in hindsight [ __ ] great show
later you're like oh yeah [ __ ]
Gavi a joke then put the show [ __ ]
Joe he wasn't no joke but that's alright
yeah it's pretty cool they had a damn
truck or something and it unfolded like
a transformer turned into a robot
shooting them out of it my ears were
ringing for two [ __ ] days they were
all going all out how loud that [ __ ]
girl was oh I had to back off of it and
go up into the bleachers
yeah cuz they had because it was just it
was just [ __ ] my head up I kind of
feel like all the live shows I've been
to and it must be said like the [ __ ]
I've pretty much listened to a Walkman
constantly altering the 80s which
probably can sure
to my shitty hearing yeah well but yeah
so I can't believe I didn't mention
echoing the Bunnymen other ones we
didn't mention which is stupid I can't
believe we forgot to mention Duran Duran
because I love Duran Duran about
legendary pink dots legendary pink dots
like I said [ __ ] Psychedelic Furs
modern English I thought Psychedelic
Furs for free at the bandshell in
Daytona Beach during spring break yeah
like I don't remember how old I was
maybe 17 18 something like that but they
came and I was them and might have been
[ __ ] my tea lemon drops I wanted to say
and I didn't D I saw everybody live
everybody yeah I was in Detroit it was
every single person yeah up in Detroit
see Skinny Puppy live before they were
kind of famous I never got used to get
all their demo tapes and we just give
him a cursory death though um [ __ ]
Sisters of Mercy saw them live that was
yeah I've seen them a bunch of yeah um I
really a good act and I've told this
before to Jenny the best the best bad
I've ever seen live the best performance
ever was Billy Idol yeah Billy Idol the
wit whiplash
smile tour and the cult and the cult
opened up for him that was [ __ ]
awesome
I bet Billy Idol if I could blew it out
of the park that dude is outstanding
live Steve Stevens just it sounds like
it does on the record but it's you know
you know it's live yeah it's new you
know he's not lip-synching doing a Milli
Vanilli or anything that's how that's
how good that sound quality was the
girls are just [ __ ] going crazy new
wave and punk rock girls everywhere yeah
but it was around 87 88 so my I like
Billy I owe a lot in fact but I'm not
I've never been a huge fan of the cult I
liked some of their early death rocky
stuff when they were still southern
death cult and then they were death cult
for a while and then they were the cult
and they kind of went a little bit of a
more glam rock or metal direction and I
was kind of like that's alright but it's
I never bought anything of theirs you
know what I mean so the sugar cubes when
I have Bjork in it saw PIL they were all
together sugar gems PIL a new order like
in a whole show I missed the Sabbath
yeah do what we ordered was boring it
was like is boring they're a great band
but I can see how maybe that is what
it's just like when I went to see like
VNV nation who I saw a couple times in
Tampa and it's like I like their albums
but it's just two dudes like they don't
know thank you boys just pretty much
Bjork's very good live and of course
[ __ ] John Lydon [ __ ] just blows
dalla with Johnny rod just close down
the [ __ ] Park I never got to see the
best musician have ever seen live a
Stevie Ray Vaughan [ __ ] was just
it was like seeing Jimi Hendrix yeah he
died of a couple years later oh well you
guys see him worried out yes like so
it's Psalm weather couldn't stand the
weather tour yeah yeah I'm trying to
think of other ones cuz I I can't also
can't believe that I didn't mention
swans because I'm super into them yeah
also the cramps
yeah saw them live I saw them live to a
year or two before Lux interior died and
he was still in really good she's just
like skinny and he was climbing all over
the [ __ ] stage yet this like this red
leather thing or red vinyl I guess it
was like with leopard print like this is
red leopard print for a good outfit and
he's like just climbing all over the
[ __ ] stage and he had to be who's in
his 50s or 60s at that point I was in
the front row [ __ ] at Venus de Milo
or access tower which one it was that
down in Boston saw Glenn Danzig live at
when he was at his Zenith and that was
like how the gods killed tor he was
[ __ ] fantastic I grabbed his [ __ ]
shoe like that satanic powerful he put
up with it too you knew I was getting
vampire energy next to me I have three
[ __ ] Japanese girls college girls in
that dress like something out down 50s
and they couldn't speak any English they
were getting crushed up the stage next
week they were going [ __ ] crazy well
yeah they loved it they were like a
college freshman yeah yeah college
freshman girls we also forgot to mention
the Jesus and Mary Chain who I'm really
into yeah also I like a lot of like I
say even like some of sort of the late
like kind of more California style punk
rock I mean we've probably talked about
the Dead Kennedys before I'm really into
them I also really like Minor Threat
from DC I really like Bad Religion
actually and I've seen them a whole
bunch
times and then those like I like some
kind of random [ __ ] they might be giants
Lloyd Cole and the commotions that
petrel emotion if anybody remembers them
camper van Beethoven The Pogues oh and
also XTC I [ __ ] love xdc and we didn't
mention fields in the nephilim either
yeah they went kind of metal later - I
guess cuz I bought I bought one of their
albums that came out [ __ ] probably five
six years ago and it's almost a straight
like gothic metal oh yeah and then there
was the mission UK yeah I wasn't as big
a fan of them as they had some good
songs they did have some good songs
though they were a little they went a
little poppy for me kind of sounded like
you - a bit like you - I love although I
like early you - yeah you early you -
it's really good like boy and war yeah
like those two good but after that's the
Joshua tree I didn't seem to get used to
that one yeah it's just on the radios on
all the [ __ ] time
yeah and that I feel like that kind of
happened to Depeche Mode too because
even though like when I was growing up
and I was really into you know the
Smiths and the Cure and Depeche Mode and
stuff you know among other things also
the by lease remember them yeah well
that was the first album I bought yeah
with my own money was synchronicity a
panacea the police was good and I still
listen to that now I really like that
album but um I think the problem
occurred when particularly in right
around 89 or 90 when you know when
Depeche Mode came out violator and the
Cure came out with [ __ ]
disintegration aggression and then it
kind of just blew up and it went
mainstream 1990 I saw the Cure and that
was it Orlando Arena is like 50
bajillion people there I saw a Depeche
Mode and nights are ebb and I also saw
them in 1990 and those 50 bajillion
people there at which point I was just
kind of like everybody likes this [ __ ]
now and it's just seemed like it was
going too much toward because I mean
Depeche Mode in particular my favorite
albums of theirs were probably some
great reward like their real early stuff
like pre-1986
you know what I mean if you guys like
goth music you don't
but you don't like the cure or you don't
know the cure would ever listen to
pornography that's that album called the
pornography out any to you that Katie to
[ __ ] just I love that album that's
easily my favorite yeah album and still
is well they got a lot of good ones you
know they do it's hard to say kiss me
kiss me yeah good one disintegration the
top oh yeah I like the top even though
it's kind of all over the place you like
somatically but that's kind of one of
the things I like about it
yeah hit on the door like that also a
good one yeah but yeah even um there was
one I didn't like it for a long time but
it kind of grew on me it was the one
after [ __ ] kiss me was it called now
I wish oh yeah I didn't like that one
yeah I didn't like it either but it kept
listening to it and I was like man this
is all so now I mean I could listen to
it now maybe and I'd have a different
because I don't even remember hardly
anything about it cuz that's the one
with Friday I'm in love honor right yeah
when it came I still don't like that
came out I didn't like it but then I
just kept listening to it and I was like
now this talk is pretty good it takes a
while to see some [ __ ] where it has to
grow on you it's like you know what I
mean and even like some albums by bands
I like like sometimes I'll get a new one
and I'll listen to it I'm like man I'm
like I'll put it away for a little while
but then I'll listen to it again I'm
like oh this is actually we didn't
mention the first the first was good and
the [ __ ] early part of the firs thank
God I didn't like it went to pop
eventually what yeah I mentioned them a
little bit ago right they were um I
remember them like I remember them being
one of the first kind of New Wave
quote-unquote bands that I got into
because they used to play love my way
and pretty and pink and stuff on MTV
like that in the early like in the early
days it was them and it was like modern
English and stuff and those were among
the first like cassettes or albums that
I bought the police was the first one
that I bought but then I got like there
there was a band out there that was
tight as [ __ ] I mean they were [ __ ]
really good and they had a lot of albums
and but they're really only known for
one song but they're really good if you
have you [ __ ] happen and they're
pretty deep people don't think about it
but [ __ ] Devo yeah I [ __ ] love
Devo yeah going back from you know are
we the very first one are we not man
yeah
and then you know back and what was the
one duty now for the future
[ __ ] hasn't really good what then
there was freedom of choice yeah yeah a
new traditionalist so much good [ __ ]
from back yeah a lot of good stuff boy
go boy go yeah like all kind of got
about them there's like so many good
bands format yeah they had only a lad
and what was the one there's nothing to
fear I think yeah there was another good
album
everybody knows dead man's party because
they played it like yeah that was later
that's like overplayed though yeah so oh
I wanted to say to about modern English
I think everybody knows modern English
because of I melt with you know that
album it was called after the snow it
came out in 1982 I had that whole album
and I just listened that over there it's
like yeah I mean I love that song still
even though it's you know been played
out the wazoo but um that album is still
a great [ __ ] album and not as
mainstream quote-unquote as you might
think you know no considering how
popular that song was that's like easily
the Poppaea song on it it was as good as
say like a u2 album you tube out or u2
album YouTube YouTube nobody wants that
early like a early u2 album that's how I
remembered it being then as good as that
yeah it didn't sound like that but it
was as good as that yeah I mean I wore
that [ __ ] out and it's like and I and I
recently just bought it again cuz I was
buying up like a bunch of like not you
know just downloading stuff from iTunes
and everything like that because I don't
have any of my records anymore I just
have like a few that I capped but for a
while when I was broke I sold up [ __ ]
ton of them on eBay and I didn't have a
record player so I figured I might as
well get rid of him even though now all
they're coming back I know it's like now
I wish I had a bunch of that stuff
because I had and [ __ ] for a long time
because I was super ended like Duran
Duran when I was um you don't like the
early to mid 80s and then for whatever
reason like for a while I went off them
it's like that's too poppy that's too
mainstream and [ __ ] like that so I had
this huge box of Duran Duran stuff I had
like all these [ __ ] 12-inch singles
adults rare [ __ ] that I had got for like
from Europe and all this other stuff and
I gave it all to a friend of mine
because she was like really into them so
a lot of money and I know I was like so
every day I wish I still had like all
that stuff so I had to go and like
download all of their albums again
because I had given all of them away
I have everything from Billy Idol
[ __ ] and it's probably like new
condition that my dad my dad's house
yeah all of them oh he's still got all
that yeah yeah I think all my records
are gone all of them are there which the
only I think the only vinyl I have left
is some rare like misfits yeah saying
that was like autographed and stuff and
I said well obviously I'm not selling
that I got to keep that [ __ ] but uh but
yeah so you want to wrap this up yeah
Thursday it's Thursday right yeah yeah
so anyway stay safe out there as usual
and we'll talk to you again tomorrow